this is from Madeline Reid looook answer
the rainforests have been known to be
attacked by a fungus which Zomba thighs
the ant and forces it to do unnatural
fungus aid behavior is it possible for a
fungus like this to attack human beings
well I don't know that we've actually
seen a fungus that turn people into
zombies but we certainly see fungi that
execute all kinds of clever activities
to force the behavior of whatever they
infect to facilitate spread of their
spores absolutely so let me give me
macroscopic viral behavior the virus
might argue that's what athlete's foot
in a gym is absolutely or the or the
particular fungus that causes you to
scratch your genitals
oh now you're sounding like Book of
Mormon there's that's if you don't bathe
Chuck oh yeah just FYI but okay so and
fungi since they taste good they have a
way to get into all of our bodies
especially shiitake yeah but yeah they
we are surrounded by spores that are
bacterial spores fungal spores they
drift in the air and in some cases they
look out and land in a proper location
in your personal ecology to cause
disease not be spread that's where it is
there we have it so basically the answer
is yes one day you will be a zombie made
from a fungus